BOTH SIDES EXPECT THIS FIGHT TO
END UP IN THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT.
BUT WE THOUGHT WAS A DONE DEAL,
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY ASKED
WEEK BY FORMER SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER MAY NOT BE.
AND TONIGHT WE ARE IS SOME
WIGGLE ROOM, AT LEAST IN THE
EYES OF THE NATION'S TOP
LAW-ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IS HERE TO
EXPLAIN.
>> WITH CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY
LOOMING, SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS
FORMER SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER REMAINS A
RELUCTANT WITNESS, AND     AND A
RELUCTANT WITNESS, AND     AND N
RELUCTANT WITNESS, AND     AND M
RELUCTANT WITNESS, AND     AND E
RELUCTANT WITNESS, AND     AND R
OF OPTIONS UNDER CONSIDERATION.
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR
SEEM TO OFFER AN EXIT RAMP.
>> IF BOB DECIDES HE DOESN'T
WANT TO BE SUBJECT TO THAT IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WOULD
CERTAINLY BACK IN.
>> MUELLER WAS SCHEDULED TO
TESTIFY NEXT WEDNESDAY BEFORE
THE DEMO TO DEMOCRAT-LED
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
HIS REPORT FOUND NO CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IN RUSSIA BUT DID NOT
"EXONERATE THE PRESIDENT ON
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE."
BARR FROWNED ON HOUSE DEMOCRATS
FOR COMPELLING MUELLER'S
TESTIMONY.
>> AM DISAPPOINTED TO SEE HIM
SUBPOENAED BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT SERVES ANY PURPOSE DRAGON
BOB MUELLER UP IF HE IN FACT
IT'S GOING TO STICK TO THE
REPORT.
IT SEEMS TO ME THE ONLY REASON
FOR DOING THAT IS TO CREATE SOME
KIND OF PUBLIC SPECTACLE.
>> IN MAY, MUELLER GAVE HIS ONLY
PUBLIC STATEMENT ON THE RUSSIAN
REPORT'S FINDINGS AND HE DID NOT
TAKE REPORTER QUESTIONS.
>> THE REPORT IS MY TESTIMONY.
I WOULD NOT PROVIDE INFORMATION
BEYOND THAT WHICH IS ALREADY
PUBLIC IN ANY APPEARANCE BEFORE
CONGRESS.
>> IN A SEPARATE DEVELOPER,
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THE FORMER
BRITISH SPY CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
BEHIND THE CONTROVERSIAL DRUM
DOSSIER, WAS SO CONCERNED THAT
HE COULD GET "THROWN UNDER THE
BUS IN A FORTHCOMING
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT" THAT
HE AGREED TO COOPERATE.
BROKE NEW DETAILS THIS MORNING
THAT HE WAS INTERVIEWED IN THE
U.K. IN JUNE BY THREE LAWYERS
WORKING FOR INSPECTOR GENERAL
MICHAEL E HORWITZ, WHO IS
INVESTIGATING ALLEGED